hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and Asta is about
to unlock his ultimate power-up a new
world breaking type of magic or
anti-magic or maybe it's something in
between asta's final training Arc is
leading up to the greatest twist in the
entire story and to the ultimate
showdown between Asta and the strongest
devil of all time black holes dark
matter and dark energy are all involved
so let's get into it now a quick heads
up if you are watching our video and you
enjoy our stuff please consider
subscribing over 50 of you guys are not
subscribed and it would mean a lot to me
if you did subscribing on YouTube is of
course completely free but it's a very
real way of directly supporting the
channel and of course if you have a
second leave a quick like and comment on
this video to help with that YouTube
algorithm finally this video will
contain Black Clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the previous chapters we
saw that Asta has been trying to master
his key manipulation and perfect the
zetan technique as lucius's paladins led
by sister Lily invaded Hino country the
paladins even used Beast magic to revive
the legendary five-headed dragon of the
goshu region and five of the seven
ryuzen ichika included are preparing to
fight them the other two members of the
seven rusen including the strongest one
are still training Asta ryuya firmly
believes that Asta has to complete his
training before facing the paladins and
Lucius even if that means staying out of
the fight for now if you watched my
previous Black Clover video you know
that I laid out my theory for why I
think Asta and liebe's anti-magic may
evolve into black hole magic in the
final Arc of the story possibly when
anti-magic combines with dark magic
through the demon slasher Katana
remember this point because I will talk
about it again later since the latest
chapter gives us even more information
and clues to work with also to everyone
who commented on the previous Black
Clover video that I need to make more
Black Clover videos here you go on other
black lore videos so if you like it like
And subscribe okay so in the latest
chapter we are taken back to the moment
when ryuya told Asta that he must stop
his training with ichika because
powerful enemies have arrived right here
in Hino these enemies are strong enough
to destroy the entire country and Austin
being hasta he immediately wants to join
the fight against them however ryuya
tells him that he must complete his
training first he must hurry up and
master his zetan because if he doesn't
he is going to get thrashed by the enemy
and if Asta is defeated here in Hino
then he will never get the chance to
return to the Clover Kingdom and help
his friends defeat Lucius Austin
reluctantly agrees to stay out of the
fight and train with two of the seven to
use in including the very strongest
member while the other five hold off the
enemy attack the strongest member of
their use and seven is named mushuoga
take yoga and he is a powerful Katana
wielding badass just like our boy Yami
as the training unfolds Austin is pretty
much getting wrecked by Mushu oga and
much like Asta the strongest member of
the z107 is feeling a bit frustrated
about not going out to meet the enemy
directly mushuoga is anxious to get into
the fight and help his comrades but
since Ryu asked him to complete asta's
training first he is forced to respect
the shogun's wishes Asta is stunned by
how powerful Mushu oga is and Austin
knows that in his current state his
zetan is no match for this guy but even
though Asta continues to get wrecked
over and over again during this training
he is able to keep fighting thanks to 10
manasiki fujio the final member of the
reusen 7 whose magic allows him to
reduce the damn image that asta's body
is taking during his fight with mushuoga
fujio seems to be activating his magic
or yojutsu by playing abiwa and he has a
pet cat on his shoulder and this cat is
wearing a cute little scar seriously the
little cat has a tiny little scarf and
it's pretty freaking adorable anyway
Mushu oga can sense some potential in
Asta and he can see why do you put him
in charge of training Asta but mushuoga
also believes that at this rate Asta
will never successfully Master zetin
that's because Asta is hesitating far
too much and this is obvious just by
looking at the way that Asta wields his
Katana mushuoga says that once Katana
does not lie and Asta is clearly
hesitating to use his Katana because his
conviction is wavering Asta is obviously
having some serious self-confidence
issues but on the other hand because
mushuoga doesn't have any doubts
whatsoever about his abilities he is
able to successfully cut through through
literally anything in existence that is
the difference between Asta and mushuoga
at this point in the story and until
Asta learns to stop hesitating and until
he regains his confidence in battle he
will never get stronger after hearing
his opponent's words Asta realizes that
mushuga is right after he failed to
protect sister Lily took an L against
Lucius and then took another L against
ichika during training Asta lost his
confidence in battle he is having
regrets he is having doubts and this is
having a negative impact on his Katana
wielding and on his key Austin knows
that with the way that he is now he
can't possibly achieve his dream of
becoming the wizard King in fact Asta
thinks that if his main rival you know
had been the one there during lucius's
attack he would have done a better job
of protecting sister Lily and he may
have even defeated Lucius instead of
losing to him after all yuno became a
Grand magic night before Asta he keeps
getting stronger and stronger and Asta
is having serious doubts about whether
or not he will be able to keep up with
you know while I'm reading this the
whole time I'm like Asta come on bro we
all know that you're the main character
so you will become the strongest Naruto
became the Hokage not Sasuke so I think
you're pretty safe but anyway just as it
seems that Asta is about to get his act
together against Mushu oga the chapter
switches Focus to the battle between the
paladins and the other five members of
the ryu's and seven one of the members
of their use and seven is a girl named
kezukaku kinojo morifuyu and yes Tabata
is really having fun with these names
I'll tell you right now trying to
pronounce them while still keeping my
Wii credentials is not easy before she
draws her sword this girl seems very
timid and even terrified of her opponent
but as soon as she draws her sword she
turns into a wild yandere she attacks
sister Lily at great speed and actually
manages to cut her cheek in the first
attack which completely shocks Lily and
that is actually how the latest chapter
ends the strongest Mages in Hino are
fighting the paladins and the giant
dragon Asta is about to unlock his
ultimate power-up and who knows what
crazy stuff is happening right now back
in the Clover Kingdom this is a very
exciting time in the Black Clover manga
and I can't wait to see what's going to
happen next now back to asta's Ultimate
power-up and what his ultimate form and
final power will actually look like as I
said before I believe that his
anti-magic will ultimately evolve into
black hole magic possibly with the help
of Yami and ichika's dark magic a black
hole has the ability to warp gravity
space and time and those are literally
the three magic types of the three
strongest Devils so black hole magic
could be the a perfect counter to all
three of those Devils but something I
didn't consider in my previous video and
something that could play a major role
in Austin's ultimate power-up is the
concept of dark matter and dark energy
now I'm no astrophysicist or particle
physicist but I do watch kurska's act
videos so I think I'm qualified to talk
about theoretical physics actually no
I'm definitely not but Black Clover is a
fantasy series so we don't have to take
real world physics too seriously they're
mostly just a Rough Guide for how things
work in Black Clover and it's definitely
not a one-to-one comparison so as any
good kurska's act viewer will know less
than five percent of the known universe
is made of conventional matter meaning
the things that form stars and planets
and trees and living creatures the stuff
we can see 25 of the universe is made up
of dark matter and 70 is made up of dark
energy both of which are completely
invisible and can't be effectively
studied or measured but we know that
dark matter and dark energy exist
because the gravity of normal matter is
not strong enough to form galaxies and
other complex structures within our
universe if the universe had been made
up of only conventional matter planets
would likely be scattered all over the
place and galaxies would not be able to
form properly that means that the
universe as we know it would literally
not exist it could not exist as a result
we know there is something else inside
and around planets and galaxies and all
conventional matter something that
doesn't emit or reflect light and is
therefore dark invisible the best we can
do is observe that certain areas of
space with particularly high
concentrations of Dark Matter actually
bend the light that is passing nearby so
we know there is something there that
interacts with gravity so dark matter
and dark energy cannot be seen but their
effects can be observed quite clearly we
also know that the universe is expanding
and that this expansion is accelerating
new space is constantly being created as
the universe expands and dark energy is
intrinsic to empty space it is also
stronger than anything else we know and
it keeps getting stronger over time in
other words even empty space has its own
energy its own dark energy and dark
energy has more energy than anything
else in the universe combined Dark
Energy permeates the entire universe it
is everywhere but it has the opposite
effect on the universe than normal
energy and matter do and that kind of
reminds me of how anti-magic seems to
work in Black Clover it clearly exists
within a world full of magic and yet it
seems to have the opposite effect on
that world when compared to regular
magic so far anti-magic has only been
Associated specifically with libe and
Asta is the only human k capable of
wielding it because he himself has no
magic but liebe was also born without
magic at least allegedly his ability to
use anti-magic only appeared after he
was sealed inside the five-leaf grimoire
with the help of lichita's absorption
and ceiling magic which in the process
of sealing liebe away for his own safety
also seemed to absorb some of lucifero's
magic and transfer it into the grimoire
while inside the grimoire the Furious
liebus wore Vengeance against lucifero
and all the devils and he vowed to kill
them all eventually while stuck inside
the grimoire liebe somehow develops the
ability to use anti-magic and Asta is
able to use it as well when he
eventually takes possession of that very
same grimoire but what if anti-magic
isn't just a special power that is
unique to leave it alone what if
anti-magic in Black Clover is more like
antimatter or dark matter in our own
world what if it is actually everywhere
and in all things what if fancy magic is
just the dark counterpart of magic and
the world is actually full of it but
under normal circumstances there is no
way to actually access it or act upon it
it is just a mysterious Force like dark
energy in our own world always
permeating everything but completely
invisible and Untouchable to us we know
it's there we know it's stronger than
anything else we know of but we cannot
act upon it we can't do anything with it
however lychee does magic acting upon
lucifero's magic and the five leaf
grimoire somehow opened a gateway to
accessing anti-magic for liebe or I
should say accessing just one small
fraction of the full extent of
anti-magic's power what if there is just
as much anti-magic in the world of Black
Clover as there is Magic itself if not
more and what if as part of their final
power up Austin liebe will learn to
access and control more and more of this
mysterious Dark Energy what if
anti-magic when fully unlocked is an
absolutely insane world-breaking power
that has the ability to negate all magic
in the universe and may even be able to
destroy the entire world of Black Clover
as we know it if anti-magic permeates
everything in the world of Black Clover
and Austin liebe learned to tap into it
they will have access to the single most
powerful energy in the universe the
fantasy equivalent of dark energy this
dark energy which is present in
everything even in empty space would
allow anyone who fully wields it not
only to defeat Lucius and all the
strongest Devils but to become an actual
God someone with the power to break and
remake the entire world the entire
universe
personally I still think that the
simpler way for Tabata to handle asta's
final power up is to focus on the
concept of black holes and black hole
magic but it would be pretty insane to
see Tabata delve into such mysterious
Concepts as antimatter dark matter and
dark energy in a fantasy series like
Black Clover what do you guys think what
will asta's final power up be based on
black holes antimatter Dark Matter Dark
Energy infinite tsukuyomi let me know
down below if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now and
if you're one of the over 50 of people
who watch our videos but haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a huge
favor and subscribe right now it only
takes you a second it is completely free
but it helps me out a lot on YouTube as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys